St graa of the Blessed sailboat best
known for skipping school to complain
about the weather has a new object of ir
the Jews specifically gr was complaining
about the state of Israel and demanding
that climate activists stand in
solidarity with the Palestinians when a
fellow climate activist bewildered got
on stage and tried to get her to focus
we have not been listening the people in
power have not been listening I come
here for a climate demonstration not a
political
[Applause]
viate Justice
unoccupied no climate Justice unoccupied
land no climate Justice unoccupied
land no climate Justice on occupied land
what could that possibly mean even
putting aside the ridiculous phrase
climate Justice the notion that we owe
something to The Rock box in the air or
whatever put that aside for a moment is
graa saying that we can't recycle until
we abolish the state of Israel that we
can't limit carbon emissions until the
Palestinians get a nation state what
could that possibly
mean but pro- Palestine activism was not
Great's only digression of the day she
then also took part in an anti-
capitalism march marching through the
streets waving all sorts of weirdo
radical
Flags Great marching with them some
environmentalists like that guy who
tried to take her microphone are are
bewildered totally befuddled they should
not be some people like that guy
actually believe that climate Justice is
not political when it is in fact the
most political movement of all on the
left of course St graa supports all of
the other liberal causes the only reason
reason that she has had so much success
focusing on environmentalism is because
environmentalism is the fundamental
religious premise of all of the other
left-wing activism it's the inversion of
man's place in the order of creation
it's the belief that we must serve
rather than Steward nature it's the
idolatry of the natural world and the
worship of creation rather than of the
Creator I'm Michael nolles this is the
Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we got a we got
a new Squad in town move over AOC and
Rashida TB we got Trump Dana White
Tucker D Jr and Kid Rock rolling into a
UFC match Crowd Goes totally wild for
them not Bill bur's wife who actually
flips Trump off we'll get to all of that
in a that very important story in a
moment first though I don't want to move
off of religion too quickly because that
is the fundamental background religious
principle for the left is the
environmentalism because
environmentalism is not just about
saving the Delta smelt or preventing the
bald eagles from going extinct
environmentalism smuggles in all sorts
of ridiculous premises and and first
principles about man's place in creation
about what we're here to do about how we
came to be about what the purpose of
life is so on this battle of religion on
this holy war that we seem to be engaged
in right now uh we've got some good news
actually from the religious side as
opposed to the irreligious side the good
news is a survey just came out which
found that Progressive
priests are going
extinct there among the new priests who
are coming up in seminary who are one
day going to lead the church we hope
there are basically no progressives to
be
found major survey finds that
conservative and lowercase o Orthodox
priests are on the rise Progressive
simply put says the report the the
portion of new priests who see
themselves as politically liberal or
theologically Progressive has been
steadily declining since the second
Vatican Council and has now all but V
more than half of the priests who were
ordained since 2010 see themselves on
the conservative side of the scale no
surveyed priests who were ordained after
20120 described themselves as very
Progressive 85% of the youngest cohorts
says they're conservative Orthodox or
very conservative Orthodox and only 14%
describe themselves as middle of the
road which leaves what 1% or something
say that they're Progressive and not
only is this great news that is worth
celebrating not only is this a glimmer
of hope as we have a crisis throughout
our political order and no surprise a
crisis within the church which leads the
political order sometimes reacts to it
but often leads it uh but this also
should be
unsurprising they say the blood of the
martyrs is the seed of the church the
persecution of the church is not an
abration it's it's uh not this little
weird fact of history that present
something that sometimes goes wrong it's
actually a feature it's not a bug it's a
feature of the system and it's it's what
has allowed the church to
spread religious life is always
difficult meaning people call to a
vocation to be a priest to be a nun to
be a a brother or sister a monk it's
it's very difficult you give a lot up
you abstain from a lot of the pleasures
of this world it's especially difficult
today when so many people in society
think it's all totally bunk so they
think that there's no point to it
which means that those who are drawn to
religious life and who are actually in
our extremely hedonistic decade and age
who are willing to give up the pleasures
of this world probably really believe it
furthermore in a world in which the left
has taken over basically every single
institution they have pretty much all of
the influence in society if you are a
young liberal or leftist who's trying to
gain some influence who wants to leave
your mark on the world they're plenty of
other places for you to go beyond the
church the the church's political power
has waned significantly in recent
decades which is a bad thing in itself
but it's maybe a good thing in this
sense in that if you want to have an
influence on society and you're a
leftist since the 1960s and70s you can
just go to the university you're going
to be able to shape a lot of Minds at
the University you're going to make a
lot of money you're going to get to do
whatever weirdo stuff you want to do so
you're going to go there maybe you're
going to go into government maybe you're
going to go into Corporate America the
libs took over Corporate America too
you'll go become a a Dei Deputy middl
managing Dean director of whatever
nonsense diversity some Fortune 500
company is going to be pushing and you
get to make some money and you get to do
your weird stuff and you don't need to
deal with the rigors of religious life
if you're a lib you would just as soon
go into all of those other fields which
means that there has been a process of
experation and purification going on
within the church and some people who
are a little older
toward the top end of the church don't
really seem to like this very much
unfortunately the the church hierarchy
is not going to accept this conservative
Trend without a fight and I mention this
even for the people who are not
Catholics who are not self-identifying
as Christians more broadly who are not
religious at
all the Christianity is the animating
Spirit of our civilization so as goes
Christianity so goes the civilization
even if you're the most hardened atheist
and by the way one of the most hardened
atheists in the world has just converted
we'll get to that perhaps a little bit
later today uh but there's some sad news
over the weekend which is that Pope
Francis has relieved a very popular very
holy very good conservative Bishop of
his duties that would be Bishop
Strickland in Texas uh wonderful Bishop
very well-liked and more importantly
than being well-liked very good at his
job and very good at shepher Souls uh
it's unfortunate it's above my pay rate
I don't make decisions but it's very
very sad it's very disappointing and it
just reminds me of this bizarre fact
about our culture even beyond the church
even just in our whole political life
which is
that the boomers are so insistent on
telling us what the youths want the
Boomers who came up during the Age of
Aquarius the hippie generation they're
going to remake everything they're going
to start the world from scratch
everything's going to be new and
revolutionary man they're so insistent
on telling us what the youths want and
yet
today what the youths want is totally
contrary to what the Boomer hippies want
and they can't grapple with this you see
this in the church the Boomers who
promote the the so-called new Mass the
kind of 1970s hippie dippy you know sing
along kumbai y let's let's listen to
feminine ballads that weren't even cool
in the 1970s the youths want the
traditional Latin mass in our political
order the the hippie dippy people they
want just do what you want man do a
bunch of drugs and have sex with anyone
and anything that appeals to you and
just you know kind of you do you and
I'll do me that's not what the young
people want I I spent a lot of time with
young conservatives I travel this entire
country I travel the world in fact
talking to Young conservatives all the
young conservatives are much more
traditional they're much more socially
conservative they're much more
interested in order and flourishing and
beauty and truth and goodness and virtue
than the Boomer look I love my Boomer
friends I don't mean to be too harsh on
the Boomers but as a generation that
generation tends to be far more lay Fair
do what you want just don't make it
affect me man and don't make me pay more
taxes for
it it would seem clear to me as a little
glimmer of hope that uh those Boomers
who just they they're so certain they
know what the youths want we know how to
attract the youths back to the church
ultimately back to the conservative
movement back to patriotism they just
they kind of went wrong as a generation
Gen X I think in their lazy Fair
apathetic attitude they went a little
wrong my Millennial Generation boy oh
boy did the Millennials go wrong we're
the Obama generation but the Zoomers man
the Zoomers are giving me hope and
you're seeing it at every level of
society among the so-called activists in
Corporate America in the political order
and even as high as the church that's
good stuff so there's going to be a lot
of friction there's going to be tension
there's going to be up heal and during
those periods of uncertainty you're
going to want to check out Birch gold
right now text Noles to 98 9898 yet
again we are facing the threat of a
government shutdown later this month and
yet again the administration will deal
with it the same way they always do with
more spending more spending will
inevitably devalue the dollar protect
your savings by diversifying into gold
with the help of Birch gold group here's
the best part when you open an IRA with
Birch gold for every $10,000 you spend
by December 22nd Birch gold will send
you a free gold bar just text nolles KS
to 98 9898 to claim eligibility before
Black Friday Birch gold can even help
you convert an existing Ira or 401K into
an IRA in Gold without taking any money
out of pocket are you listening you get
a free gold bar multiple free gold bars
depending on how much money you put in
with an A+ rating with a Better Business
Bureau and thousands of satisfied
customers you can count on Birch gold to
help you transition an existing Ira or
401K into an IRA in Gold do not let your
savings fall victim to the further
devaluation of the dollar Tex NES cans
to 98 9898 receive a free info kit on
gold claim your eligibility before Black
Friday to receive free gold bars on your
qualifying purchase that is nolles text
it to 9898 98 speaking of going down
without a fight or with a fight I guess
the FBI has seized New York city mayor
Eric Adams's phone and iPad amid a
federal corruption
investigation this is very strange
because New York city mayor Eric Adams
he's a
Democrat he's a fairly liberal Democrat
but actually recently mayor Adams has
has been saying some things that the
Liberals don't
like so the allegations here are that
mayor Adams's 2021 campaign colluded
with the
Turks usually we talk about colluding
with the Russians or colluding with the
ukrainians sometimes colluding with the
Chinese this is a new one apparently
Eric Adams colluded with the Turks all
right add that to the list the
allegation is that he received illegal
campaign donations from the Turkish
government and what are those donations
according to the New York Post campaign
records show that mayor Adams accepted
$6,000 from three donors who served on a
board backed by the son of the Turkish
president erdogan
seriously that hold on let me did I get
that must be $6 million right no 600,000
no not even 60 thou
$6,000 from three donors who are on a
board with the son of the leader of this
hold on this isn't this isn't adding up
to me
until I realized wait a second this
doesn't have anything to do with
campaign Don ations the reason that the
libs and the liberal enforcement
institution the FBI are going after
Adams right now is cuz he said this
110,000
migrants we have to feed clothes house
educate the children wash their laundry
sheets give them everything they need
health care we're getting no support on
this National
crisis and we're receiving no support
and let me tell you something New
Yorkers never in my life have I had a
problem that I did not see an ending to
I don't see an ending to
this I don't see an ending to this this
issue will destroy New York City destroy
New York City there it is oh boy there
it is this was my first reaction when I
I saw the headline Eric Adams
investigated I thought oh that guy piped
up a little too much about immigration
didn't he that was his mistake it I
don't think it has to do with $6,000
from some people who once went to a
Turkish bath on 11th street or something
I don't think it's because a couple guys
ate Falafel one day and they gave Eric
Adams a high five and now he's under
investigation nah this guy spoke up
against something that the Liberals have
to support which is endless Mass
migration
and he he broke the script
here and he he broke with the
long-standing Democrat tradition of
flooding the country with foreign
Nationals and in particular he
criticized Joe Biden he's saying Joe
Biden your policy is bad he embarrassed
the sitting Democrat president and then
what do you know the highly politicized
investigative and law enforcement arm
run ultimately by that President starts
poking around Eric Adams's cell phone
and iPad
had looks like someone spoke up a little
too much and then I I don't want to be a
tinfoil hack guy I really don't want to
defend a Democrat mayor of New York but
I got to go where the facts lead me and
in the reporting on this investigation
into Adams says following news of the
investigation Adams canceled his plan to
discuss illegal immigration and the
Border crisis with the Biden
Administration there we go I hadn't even
read that part before I came to my
conclusion my knee-jerk conclusion this
has got to be about illegal immigration
which it is so now they start
threatening Adams and he says okay okay
I'll back off okay we I won't I won't
meet with the Biden admin to talk about
this problem okay I'll cool it and stop
admitting that illegal immigr I'll stop
admitting publicly at least that illegal
immigration will destroy New York City
which we all know including the liberal
Democrat
mayor now speaking of cleaning up cities
a miracle happened over the weekend a
miracle something no one thought Poss
very few people thought possible
San Francisco which in recent years has
become a complete garbage heap San
Francisco which is now riddled with on
the streets human excrement and people
lying out dying potentially of exposure
shooting up dying of overdoses when
they're not dying of exposure just crime
and filth filling the city people
fleeing what was once one of the most
beautiful cities in the
country Nome cleaned it all up they
cleaned up we have before pictures we
got after pictures in San Francisco and
just look wow the camps are gone the
trash is gone the bums have been
shuffled
off it's all it's all better how did
they do that well it's all gone
because xiin ping is coming to San
Francisco all it took to clean up one of
America's once great cities was for a
Chinese Communist dictator come visit
and then the Civil Authority decides
they're going to clean it up here here's
how the news is describing it
while San Francisco is in the spotlight
for the asia-pacific economic conference
city leaders are making sure the city
shines tourism is our business here in
San Francisco and we need to focus on
making sure that the tourist dollars
still come back calr repaving Major
roadways like the Harrison Street
offramp from the I80 Bart doubling down
by deep cleaning their stations
overnight more often the city had gotten
a little bit dingy over time scrubbing
and power washing is happening all over
the city yeah the bottom of my shoes
look clean like it's noticeable how
clear the streets look and how few
homeless encampments there are on major
thoroughfares wow they fixed it which
they always could have done they just
they weren't going to fix it for you
they weren't going to fix it for the
residents of San Francisco or of
California or for
Americans forget about just making sure
the bottom of your shoes are clean don't
forget every day that vagrants are
allowed to sit out and shoot up heroin
or fenel on the Streets of San Francisco
more and more Americans are dying
they're being killed if you ask me
they're being poisoned and they're being
allowed to poison themselves by the
Civil Authority so it's having a real
body count every day that that's allowed
to go on but that's fine when the only
people affected are Americans but when
we want to impress a Chinese dictator
well then we got to clean it up and it
and it was done quickly matter of days
they fixed the whole city of course
there are a lot of political problems
that we pretend just can't be fixed well
you know the Border crisis we can't what
can we do about that there's nothing to
be done even if we want the walls don't
work the Border Protection agents they
it doesn't work they can't yes they can
do you remember during the early days of
coid they locked that down pretty
quick if when they wanted to and then
when they didn't want to they didn't do
you remember in the it can be
done when when the cops have actually
cracked down on crime you see it in New
York City when a Republican mayor took
over they fixed New York City which was
one of the most crime ridden cities in
the country they fixed it almost
overnight because Giuliani cared about
it this can always be done when it comes
to cleaning up the street when it comes
to criminal justice when it comes to
election Integrity they can lock that
stuff down fast the reason that they're
not doing that the reason that cities
which xinping has not decided to visit
are still filthy and full of crime and
full of drugs and people are killing
themselves is not because of
incompetence that is an intentional
policy by the liberal politicians who
could fix it in a jiffy they could fix
it in 24 hours even nelini over there
governor Patrick baitman and California
who many have said is feckless can't get
anything done no he's he's effective
when he wants to be they just don't want
to
be when it's just a bunch of Americans
living in filth and squalor and crime
and
dying they they don't need to do their
jobs but the asia-pacific conference is
shishan Ping is here all right we we'll
impress the Chinese Communists that's
fun not a great look now when you want
to look really good you got to check out
Jus cell right now go to Jus cell.com
NES if you can believe it Thanksgiving
is just two weeks away just in time for
the holidays jell is offering their best
sale of the year right now you can get
70 70% off genus cell's most popular
package which now includes genus cell 3
their newest under ey treatment you know
I got to catch up with my friends at Jus
Cell last week and we were talking about
the 70% off and we were kind of asking
hey how do you
how do you do that are you are your
prices just kind of really marked up so
you have that much margin and the answer
is no the reason that Jus cell can
afford to give you 70% off on their most
popular package is because they know
that you're going to love the product
and that you're going to keep getting
products down the line for months and
years afterward that's how good it is
and they're so confident that they're
actually willing to take a loss and give
you an incredible value to start and I
know that you're going to love it just
like everyone in the office loves Jus
cell go to jus.com to get this incred
credible holiday discount 70% off their
most popular package this includes the
JSL 3 and Dark Spot Corrector get result
in 12 hours or less the immediate
effects are included for free Jas
cell.com for 77% off today plus free
priority shipping genucell.com
NS today despite the lackluster economy
the daily wire is thriving and we are
hiring we are currently looking to add
an eager inside sales representative to
our ad sales team this position will be
responsible for identifying new accounts
and fostering relationships with clients
knowledge of our brand as well as
experience in digital media sales are
required if you match this description
we want to hear from you the position is
based in Nashville Tennessee if you're
interested in joining our team visit
dailywire.com careers that is
dailywire.com
careers
today speaking of people who want to be
president moving on from Gavin Newsome
for a second the results are in from the
presidential debate last week I'm not
talking about who won the debate I have
my thoughts on it some people have
differed but really nobody who was on
that stage won the debate because very
few people watched 7 and a half million
people watched that debate which was
hosted by NBC this is down from 9 a half
million people who watched the Fox News
debate on September
27th but even that 9 and a half million
people doesn't matter because that is
down from the 24 million people who
watched the GOP Primary debate in 2015
2015 first GOP Primary debate you get 24
million people the next GOP Primary
debate you get 22.9 million people so
you lose a million and a half people but
it's still a much larger number than
you're looking at here in this case you
lose two million people between the
previous debate and the most recent
debate but the numberers n and a half
down to seven and a half which is
telling because it's not just about
people cutting the cord it's not just
about people not subscribing to NBC
anymore you could watch this thing on
YouTube
you always
can it's that people know the debate is
inconsequential so I I kept an open mind
I watched it especially because I was
going on Megan Kelly show the next day
and I promised her I would watch it to
have a take but frankly if I had not
promised Megan that I would go over the
debate with her the next day I'm not
sure I would have watched I probably
would have watched a few Clips I would
have presented them for your enjoyment
and entertainment on this show but I
would not have treated the debate as
something consequential because it isn't
the polls are not really going to move
even if you love Ronda santis even if
you love Nikki Haley even if you even if
you love Chris Christie the Chris's
about to
happen we all know that the debate
doesn't really
matter not only do the debates not move
the poll numbers nothing seems to move
the poll numbers the only way the poll
numbers have moved since this election
season started is a little bit more in
the favor of the front runner and a
little bit away from the
challengers Trump is now up on all of
these
Challengers anywhere from 46 to 56
points that's just the people who are on
the stage so if the candidates want to
turn it around they've got to do it
somewhere other than the debate but I'm
not sure where that is even in Iowa
there now Dan santis is betting his
campaign on Iowa which is a dubious
strategy because Iowa generally does not
predict the Republican
nominee but even if he's doing that the
poll numbers don't seem to be moving the
the caucus goers who have committed
their ballots don't seem to be moving in
the direction of anyone other than Trump
now Nikki Hale is making moves in New
Hampshire she's making moves in South
Carolina
okay the the question for all of these
campaigns is what could they even
possibly do at this point to make a
difference and if the answer is nothing
if the answer at least at the debates is
nothing why are we still having debates
what's the point of
it is this primary
not saying it's totally over but is it
for all intents and purposes most likely
over even the head of the RNC Ronnie
McDaniel seems to be saying that she was
just asked on CNN if let's say that the
primary continues as it has been
trending since day one of the primary
and Trump becomes the nominee well what
happens if he gets convicted the odds of
him getting convicted in any of these
cases about 100% the the Democrats are
throwing the kitchen sink at this guy
they're they're going after him at the
Federal level they're going after him at
the state county level these one of
these charges has to stick probably many
of them will stick so then you're in a
position where the Republican nominee
for president or the presumptive nominee
is convicted of some allegedly serious
crime and then what's going to happen is
the party going to back him here's what
the head of the RNC says if you end up
having Donald Trump as your nominee and
if he is convicted of a crime do you
believe that he would be the appropriate
nominee for the Republican Party whoever
the voters choose is the appropriate
even if even if he's a convicted
criminal I know this is newsworthy but
as party chair I'm going to support who
the voters choose and yes if they choose
Donald Trump the voters are looking at
this and they think there's a two-
tiered system of justice they don't
believe a lot of the things that are
coming out in this and they're making
these decisions and you're seeing that
reflected in the polls okay what she's
said here whatever you think of Rona
McDaniel is totally right it's the right
thing to do of course the RNC should
back the candidate that the Republican
voters want to nominate especially in
this case where the confounding factor
is this absurd attack on Trump this
political persecution that's based on
nothing if the man had committed a
serious crime if he had seriously done
that then I guess there would be a
conversation to be had but the fact that
the best thing that they can throw at
Donald Trump is that he he ravished a
woman in the Berg dworf Goodman dressing
room 30 years ago allegedly even though
there's no evidence that that happened
whatsoever a lot of evidence it didn't
happen if the best they've got on him is
that he as the sitting president of the
United States called up the Georgia
Secretary of State and said hey I think
there was fraud in the election can you
look into that for me it's completely
absurd the fact that they're going after
him and they're saying that his
beautiful oceanfront property two double
oceanfront property because it spans the
entirety of PM beach one of the most
beautiful and valuable real estate
locations in the United States that it's
worthless and therefore they're going to
take his company away from him it's just
so Preposterous and even the Democrats
know it many of the Democrats at least
even The Independents certainly know it
in fact we we now have another poll that
just came out a signal poll from
November showing that that Donald Trump
is leading Joe Biden among independent
voters right now among Independence it's
not even all that close Trump 44 Biden
38 18 undecided so you know could swing
either way but Trump is leading among
all voters Biden is still beating Trump
47 to
45 but you might say okay well that's
evidence that we need to replace Trump
with some other Republican but according
to the poll Joe Biden is doing even
better against a generic Republican so
Biden beats Trump by two points it it
head-to-head Biden beats a generic
Republican by four points but usually
the generic Republican would be doing
better because the generic Republican is
just a blank slate that you could
project whatever you want onto in this
case however it's
flipped which means that once you
replace generic Republican with any of
the other candidates the numbers are
going to get even
worse whether you hate the guy or love
the guy Donald Trump is just something a
little bit different in politics you saw
this when he rolls up to UFC with Tucker
Carlson Don Jr Kid Rock and Dana White
and The Crowd Goes
Crazy how strong that team is making his
way into the building one of the bigger
mix marks the lch fans I know president
Donald Trump taking his octagon side
seat for UFC
[Applause]
[Music]
295 we got two title fights coming up at
UFC 295 here in a matter of moments live
from Madison Square
Garden and president Trump will be here
to witness all of it four of the there
he is they're going
crazy imagine Mitt Romney walking into
the UFC
Stadium what wait oh who is that M okay
never mind let's go get a beer you know
it's it's not it's not Trump and Tucker
It's Mitt Romney and Jake Tapper walking
into the stadium and The Crowd Goes Wild
no of course not
and this is by the way this is Trump
what what are we at now eight years
after he first declared he was running
for
president and then one the following
year and even after all that the crowd
still loves him but it's not the crowd
of the nice Washington DC think tanks
that many of whom hate his guts it's not
the crowd that reacts to the Mitt Romney
of the world it's the UFC fans with one
exception the comedian Bill Burr was
sitting there and he's sitting there and
he's looking respectful as Trump walks
by they're all sitting you know ringside
and Bill Burr's wife flips off Donald
Trump right in front of the camera and
everybody is attacking Bill Burr and
Bill bur's wife for this I think I'm GNA
lay off him one I think Bill Burr is a
pretty funny guy what his what his wife
did is extremely unfortunate and sad and
if it were my it would never be my wife
cuz sweet little Alisa is a civilized
woman but you know if it were my wife
we'd probably have a little chat when we
got home and say no you know honey it's
actually very bad to disrespect the
former president of the United States uh
on national television and you just
that's and just to behave like that
generally as a lady as really anyone in
public is very vulgar and not good not
not a good thing but I'm not going to
attack Bill bur I'm not really going
after his wife too hard for this
because I'm sure most people out there
myself excluded most people out there
have been with their spouses in public
and the spouse has done something kind
of embarrassing and it's I'm sure Bill
Burr is mortified by this and so I don't
Bill he's a funny guy he's I'm not going
to I'm not going to attack him for it
it's very unfortunate but in a way it's
kind of a nice Silver Lining here
because more than a silver lining it's
it's actually affirmatively helpful for
the Republicans and for Trump because it
shows you the contrast one B bur's wife
attacking Trump gets people talking
about this and then what are people
looking at how big was that Stadium I'm
going to pull a number at a thin air
let's say it was 20,000 people that
means
19,999 people in that Stadium we're
thrilled to see Trump the presumptive
Republican nominee Tucker the biggest
Cable News host and rightwing Cable News
host ever in all of history Kid Rock
very prominent right-wing musician who
blew up Bud Light with a machine
gun they all loved him one person one
very loud person did not like him
I don't know to me I like those numbers
not saying it means Trump's going to win
I'm not saying I would bet any money
that Trump is going to win in a general
election I we know that the Democrats
are very good at rigging things and the
people can be fickle too but in a fair
election when I'm looking at not just
one poll which could be faked not just
two polls which could be faked but I'm
looking at all the evidence available to
me in a fair election I like the
Republican chances the other question
about UFC here is what's Tucker doing
there what's
what's Tucker Carlson doing there at
that
fight is Trump floating Tucker for
VP some have suggested it I've floated
this idea for years at this point seems
crazy right if I were Tucker two years
ago I probably wouldn't want this why
why would he why would he want it he's
making tens of millions of dollars a
year at Fox News he's got a very
prominent perch he's the most
influential conservative on television
why would he well but then Fox News took
that from him so he's still extremely
influential he's still doing great but
he's got less to lose in terms of money
less to lose in terms of
influence and the Bas loves him who else
could run with Trump that the Bas
loves none of the people currently
running for president none of the ones
who are on that debate stage the the
nearest who could run with Trump would
probably be vake but he's he's probably
just too fresh and young to to be really
I don't know I mean maybe he he's a very
talented guy but it's not going to be
Christie it's not going to be Nikki
Haley it's not going to be Tim Scott
it's not going to be Ronda santis at
this point it couldn't be Ronda santis
because they're both from
Florida so it constitutionally wouldn't
even work if they wanted to win the
election so who's it going to be could
be some of these guys that no one really
knows about Byron Donalds as a
republican Congressman his name has been
floated could be Carrie Lake you know
but she lost her race for governor I
just don't Tucker though he's really
popular and he represents a the Trump
Trump wing of the party he represents
the Buchanan wing of the party he
represents the conservative wing of the
conservative movement in a way that the
other candidates simply
don't I don't know look maybe Trump was
just out there going to take in a nice
fight with his buddy Tucker or maybe
this was a little weather balloon maybe
they were just floating something I
don't know what do you think of the
thing that they might have been
floating what do you think about that
you know when you go into the UFC ring
and you just get your lights knocked out
that that's sometimes not very healthy
for you if you're the one actually
fighting and getting concussed but you
know what is really healthy if you're a
dog and you eat rough greens right now
go to Ruff greens.com the holidays are
coming up fast and while you're out
shopping for your kids your family your
friends don't forget to shop for your
pets too give your dog the gift of a
healthier and happier life with rough
greens naturopathic doct Dennis black
the founder of Ruff greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America dog food might as well be
considered dead food if you ask me
because it contains very little
nutritional value is nutrition Brown no
one might say it's green which is why
you got to let rough greens bring your
dog's food back to life rough greens is
a supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and the
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food just sprinkle those tasty juicy
little rough Greens on their food every
day dog owners are raving about it I
even send it to my stepbrother for his
little miniature Australian shepherd so
right now you can get a free jumpstart
trial bag so that your dog can try it
you get a free FWE baby jump start trial
bag delivered straight to your door in
just a few business days go to Ruff
greens.com or call 844 ruff1 123 that is
rfffg greens.com m i h a l or call 844
Ru FF 123 today my favorite comment on
Friday is from Matt Ray
4876 who says the fact that the witch
refers to women as womb bodies is next
level
Insanity the fact that that statement
can be uttered with a straight face and
convey meaning to me and to the audience
is perhaps even nexter leveler Insanity
wouldn't you
say there are witches there have been
witches for all of human history
virtually everyone for all of human
history everywhere has believed that
there are
witches until modern people for the last
like 5050 or so years mod liberal
atheists say that they are not witches
but everyone else including the witches
themselves say no they are witches some
they'll say no we are witches we do
these things
and she doesn't refer to women she
refers to womb bodies and what's really
crazy is not that some wacko like Devil
worshipping witch would use weird
language and dehumanizing language to
refer to human
beings what's crazier is that HR
probably uses similar language what
what's crazy is that the diversity
counselor at your PRI Public University
your very prominent Elite University
probably uses the same
language the the witchiness has spread
beyond the covens now speaking of
expanding the base there's another poll
this is the day of polls this is a poll
from CNN shows Trump leading Biden not
only among Independents but am among men
of
color 49 to
46 so it doesn't say that Trump is
leading Biden among all black people or
all PE persons of color but specifically
among men of
color Trump's leading
4946 some people are skeptical because
this is a big
difference from how the elections have
turned out in the past but what the
polling shows is that 42% of black men
are eligible
voters 12% of eligible black men voted
for Trump in 2020 87% of black men voted
for Joe Biden in 2020 now those numbers
seem to have evened out in fact in
Trump's favor look at Hispanics 58% of
Hispanic men are eligible voters 40% of
Hispanic men voted for Trump in 2020 57%
Hispanic men voted for Biden so I've
seen these numbers before that black men
and Hispanic men are now breaking for
Trump in a head-to-head I don't know if
I I was very skeptical of it the first
time I saw the poll I was very skeptical
the second time I saw the poll but I'm
I'm seeing this recur again and again
and so I I remain skeptical the only
poll that really matters is at The
Ballot
Box
but also there are uh cities with
machines that can skew results I'm
thinking of Pittsburgh I'm thinking of
Milwaukee I'm but is it possible I'm not
saying the the women of color I'm not
saying the women vote Democrat generally
but have the men of color as a sarey man
myself have the men of color begun to
wake up
perhaps think of think of the misery
Index right now think of the approval
rating that Biden is looking at think of
the fact that our country is being
humiliated and the stakes are getting
real it's no longer just a a willy-nilly
question of preferences we're now on the
brink of World War
II is it it's look I think it's possible
now speaking of support for Trump uh he
just picked up an endorsement from his
old employee Sarah Sanders who's now the
governor of Arkansas the truth is it's
not even a question anymore between
right and left it is normal versus crazy
and the left is doubling down on
crazy we've got out of control inflation
violent crime an open border a rising
China Biden and the left have failed
over and over again and they know it and
you know it and it is time for a change
[Applause]
right that is why tonight I am so proud
to endorse my former boss my friend and
everybody's favorite President Donald J
Trump all right there we go probably
only a matter of time Sarah had
initially said she was going to hold out
of the race at least for a little bit
and then she comes out and endorses him
probably the the endorsement from Sarah
was to counter the endorsement for
disantis of Kim Reynolds who's the
governor of
Iowa I love I don't know Kim Reynolds I
love Sarah Sanders love her dad Mike
Huckabee I don't think these politician
endorsements matter at all I think the
point of the politician
endorsements is to sway public opinion
and that's often how it
works I think in this race the
politician endorsements are following
public opinion I think that's why the
politicians have stayed on the sidelines
including even politicians who worked
for Trump in a very public way and then
as the election is is coming down to the
wire the politicians are following I
don't I don't think it really
matters I think that people are looking
at where the polls are moving they're
looking at crowd sizes they're looking
at
UFC things like UFC and they're seeing
Oh okay this is what's happening well
let's let's shake it out e even even Ron
McDaniel who's the head of the RNC she's
got a grit her teeth and say yeah we'll
support the the nominee even if he's a
convicted felon part of the reason for
that is Ron McDaniel only has her job
because Trump tolerates her there's a
huge call among Republicans to get rid
of Ron McDaniel but she hasn't fallen a
foul of trump yet I have a little
sympathy for her in that I'm not
convinced the leader of the RNC actually
does all that much we blame the leader
of the RNC for elections being won or
lost I think they actually have a
relatively small degree of influence in
all of it it's easy enough to blame the
person but R she she also knows where
her bread is buttered I think a lot of
Republicans are going to figure that out
too and so it it won't it won't be a
matter of these Visionary political
Governors and leaders and influencers
saying No this is the direction our
party must take it looks like the result
of this barring some extraordinary event
was baked in from the beginning and the
people as has been the case for seven
eight years now the people have begun to
lead the party against the will of the
party Elites and the smart part
go along with it lest they get run over
now speaking of prominent
women a two-time Olympic gold medalist
Carly
Lloyd she's a soccer player she has just
made a
shocking declaration she has
declared that men are better at soccer
than women she has this this woman has
just declared that men are better at
sports than women can you imagine
because someone responded to her and
said hey is it true that you guys lost
to a bunch of 15-year-old boys you
sometimes hear this that the women's
soccer team the professional women's
soccer team lost to a group of 15-year
old boys and she she responds and goes
yeah that's true I know thousands of
people have already brought that up the
boys were good we actually lost to a
youth buyer in Munich team in my career
as well but then we went on to win the
Olympics in the world cup
so yeah we we lost to boys because we're
girls but then we beat other girls
because we're relatively better at
soccer than other girls she goes haha
they should beat us they should the boys
should beat us they're bigger stronger
and faster boys always gave us a run for
our money and that was great prep what a
great attitude this woman almost could
get me to like
soccer is that's the right answer yes
the boys beat us this is not a mark of
Shame this is not something we need to
hide the boys beat us they're boys vivla
defance this is yes it's good that boys
beat us and we can actually work with
the boys they can help us train to beat
the girls cuz because we acknowledge
reality we know that they are better at
this than us that's that's that's the
right attitude to sexual difference and
you
see the
feminists men and women are totally
wrong on this where they pretend men and
women are exactly the same and it ends
up creating meoo and rape culture and
all the terrible pathologies that infect
the relation between the sexist today
but you even see this
among the red pill kind of movement
which they bring up a lot of legit make
ripes so I don't want to knock the red
pill guyses too much but their
conclusions often are very wrong and
they discuss the difference between men
and women with anger you know these
these women are so different than we are
or or these these men are are barbarians
or what you know they even try to behave
like barbarians sometimes but the
difference between the Sexes is
something to be celebrated it's lovely
it's delightful I'd like that if the
Sexes were exactly the same that would
make us all gay guys and then and that
would be which I guess there are a lot
of gay guys today and we have a very
confused sexual culture today but the
fact that men and women are different
you say oh good women they're so
different I can't even I can't
understand them they're they're so
strange they don't they drive me crazy
in many ways but isn't that fun one of
the joys of life now speaking of
prominent women there's a great story
that I'm going to
tease ion hery Ali who was raised Muslim
who has been the object of a lot of
radical Muslim a or she became an
atheist she was one of the most
prominent atheists in the world for the
past 15 or so
years she is an atheist no longer she's
not a Muslim either we'll get to what I
on herc Ali is maybe tomorrow the rest
of the show continues now you do not
want to miss it become a member use code
NS kws it check out for two months free
on all annual
[Music]
plans